It's cos she's got such great
taste, I'd want to see that—
Ah! Ow!
Seth Rogen:
-Oh sorry!
Oh no!
[Click]
[Beep]
What did come up is that there's
a—
[Laughing]
Sorry, is this right? Am I doing
this right?
[Background crew]
Ish.
I can't believe she's dating
Ska-gahn.
Skaagn?
[Laughs]
Oh, sorry.
That's a fun one, hmm?
[Bleep] you.
[bleep] you, mother (bleep).
[bleep] off.
[Laughs]
Thank you.
(Hi-five)
-You should be there.
[Laughs]
Oh wait, no, "You're a good
friend." Sorry.
-Yeah yeah.
Oh wait, sorry. Sorry, sorry,
sorry, sorry, one second, one
second, one second. [Laughs]
[Music plays]
There's a bee on you.
-[Slap]
-Ohh!
Well don't hit it!
Sorry!
-That's how they sting you!
Behind you.
-You don't hit it!
You don't?
So what— what's the deal with
these— this guy?
Let me say that again.
[Laughs]
-Um.
The-the-these guy. What— what
the deal?
-[Laughs]
Rose Byrne:
I'm going shopping. My clothes
are old.
Sha-beel..
-Wha-what?
-[Laughs]
Whoa.
You should call Will. That's
what friends do.
Um, or- or should I say, "That's
what friends do."
[Laughs]
[Beep]
That's what friends do.
-[Laughs] -What?
[Beep]
Uh, I'll just have a, um,
whatever your least gross beer is.
[Background crew]
Sorry guys, check your marks
there.
No, not at all. Way off. Way
off.
-[Crew laughs]
[Background crew]
Hey, oh!
-[Laughs]
Seth Rogen:
Alright, let's start again.
That (bleep)'s from twenty years
ago.
So is this.
Oh!
[Traffic noise]
Seth Rogen:
Can't find your mark?
[Crew laughs]
Seth Rogen:
-Laughs
[Click]
Your whole thing was so weird
and descr- des- destr-
Seth Rogen:
Destructive?
Destrinary. [Laughs]
-[Crew laughs]
Have you considered a beer
which-is?
Jizz?
No, "which is."
[Laughs]
Unfortunately for you, I am very
charming.
[Laughs]
Why the government doesn't want
you to know that the earth is
flat.
No!
They should know.
No.
-[Laughs]
Rose Byrne:
I know that I look relaxed.
But I'm not relaxed.
♪♪
I'm very angry.
[Laughing]